This is one of my favorite
topics in the course,
food agriculture. And, uh,
I'm, I'm deeply interested in,
in everybody's personal
connection to food.
You are what you eat, you are what you
breathe, you are what you drink. Um,
and we often don't have a very good
understanding of what's in our food,
what's in our era and what's in our water.
So hopefully this will sensitize
you to that problem. Uh,
and also to get you to
understand, hopefully, uh,
the structure of us environmental law
that applies to food and agriculture.
And this is an interesting area of law.
Uh,
food like plastics,
like energy.
It really does not have a distinctive,
a specific body of law that applies to it
as opposed to air and
water, uh, or pesticides.
So that's kind of curious. It's a problem
that cuts across many different areas,
many different types of regulation,
uh,
and the management of food in the U s
and the management of agriculture is
really fractured among
a number of agencies.
Great Britain recently centralized
their regulatory program and a created a
single agency to manage food.
How,
and we'll think about the wisdom of
doing that and some of the strengths and
weaknesses of the European and
British system. So to begin,
I want you to think about the
percentage of the world that, uh,
is used to grow crops or degrades lives,
livestock.
So there are 30 billion acres of land in
the world and about 4 billion acres of
those are in cropland.
So roughly about one seventh or,
or one eighth of the world is used to
grow crops within the United States.
It's about 400 million acres of land.
It's an enormous area
and it's dispersed increasingly in
a more remote areas. As cities grow,
I had a suburb sprawl,
um,
and as farmers are pushed
further and further away,
and this has a really interesting and
important implications for environmental
quality and also for human health.
So here are four crops represented in
these pictures a week in the upper left,
uh, corn. Uh, many of you
probably are unaware that a,
on a daily basis, most of us
consume cotton, uh, and a,
a variety of foods without recognizing it.
They really know in what form
oil, cotton, seed oil. It's,
it's part of a many pastries.
Uh, many different kinds of cereals. Uh,
so many breads rely on don cotton
seed oil and, and the bottom rice.
These are four major grains in the
world, uh, that, that uh, uh, uh,
uh, take up a hundreds of
millions of acres of landscape.
Corn alone in the United States is
almost 80 million acres that is currently
planted.
Increasingly in the United States,
farm size is increasing, meaning that
there are fewer and fewer farmers.
And a surprisingly,
the diversity of crops that are planted
on individual farms is also going down.
So what that means is that farming
is becoming more highly specialized,
uh, that uh, uh, farmers are
knowledgeable about fewer crops. Uh,
they have less capacity to
manage problems such as a past,
a fun guy,
a insects of different sorts because
they really don't have the fundamental
understanding of ecology that many farmers
had to have in order to survive in a
world, uh, that, uh, was not as
chemically dependent as as ours is.
Current industrialized agriculture
could be successful on a parking lot.
If you brought in soil and you brought
in fertilizer and you brought in water
and a artificially, uh, uh,
added organic matter. Uh,
so basically the more you
control your environment,
a using industrial technology,
the more expensive it becomes a,
but the less you have to worry
about understanding of college.
So it's curious that, uh, uh, you know,
as centralization is occurred in
ownership patterns, the farm's got larger.
The Crop, uh, specialty
diminished our dietary patterns.
It followed a similar, a similar pattern.
We've relied on fewer and fewer crops.
So now that most people's
diet is comprised of a between
30 to 40 different, uh,
individual crops.
So I want to talk today about what the
central problems in food and agriculture
are. Uh, and these
include food availability.
And I think most of us
understand that, uh, the,
the role of government is often been
perceived as one of trying to make sure
that we have a productive
food supply, uh, that, uh,
our agriculture is as productive as it
possibly could be so we could maximize
our exports to other countries. Uh, so
that our balance of trade would be helped.
But also so we could deal with under
nourished in impoverished parts of the
world that did not have the capacity
to grow food for whatever reason.
Food prices are going up, particularly
in the last decade. They've,
they've taken up an increasing percentage
of the average household income,
meaning that people are looking to buy
a lower cost foods and lower cost foods
are often higher calorie foods. They're
often foods that come and bulk packages.
Uh, so people are more
prone to, to buy a, the,
the leap the leader and a half bottles of
soda than they would a individual cans.
And that had, has had an influence
on patterns of food consumption.
As I mentioned,
species dependence has gone down.
We're relying on on fewer and fewer crops.
Uh,
we're genetically engineering those crops.
More and more.
A very high proportion of corn that's
planted in the United States is
genetically engineered. The same goes for
the other major greens that we produce.
Also a serious problem that
we have is that a, our,
our tastes are being cultivated
by other organizations,
particularly food processors,
uh, that, uh, are,
are adding ingredients that we don't
really pay much attention to in terms of
fat, in terms of salt, in terms of,
of sugar and a variety of artificial
flavors and colors that, uh, uh,
they do a very careful,
uh,
social surveys to understand what
kinds of tastes, what kinds of colors,
what kinds of flavors,
uh, people enjoy the most.
I use the example of the Salmo Fan.
Uh,
so that salmon is now colored in
30 dash 35 to 36 different shades,
uh, ranging from a really deep red
to a, uh, a very light coral. Uh,
so they, they did a, their
focus groups and, and, uh,
conducted surveys and figured out that
that most people like a number 33,
uh, so that, uh, that type of thinking
is pervading the food industry. Uh,
we as buyers tend to respond.
We respond by by, uh, uh, basically, uh,
looking for the lower cost foods, but
also those that, that, uh, uh, seem to,
to provide either a taste or,
or some other aesthetic appeal.
We also are consuming more calories
than we ever have before. Uh,
we are consuming on average
in the United States,
about 3,900 calories per person.
Uh,
only 15 years ago we were consuming about
3,200 calories a and that's up from,
uh, uh, perhaps, uh, uh, 27,
2,800 calories per person.
And the average shear person
with the average wait,
say 165 pound a male could
survive extremely well on a,
on a diet of about 2,400 calories per
day. Now, this would vary tremendously.
I know some of you are athletes.
Some of you may run 10 miles a day,
some of you may swim four or five
miles a day. Uh, those of you that,
that to exercise a great deal, we'll
obviously need a, a much more, uh,
a much higher caloric intake. But, uh, uh,
if you combine knowledge about what's
happened to our behavior in our
increasingly sedentary lifestyles,
uh, sitting behind computers,
watching video games,
the latest report came out only last
week demonstrating the kids are now
spending seven hours a day looking
at electronic equipment of ones,
one form or another. Uh, this
is really quite striking.
Uh, my generation, we had a,
we had televisions, uh, but, uh, you know,
television wasn't that big a
thing when I grew up. And, uh, we,
we spent a whole lot more time outdoors.
People are spending time indoors or
they're not a burning up, uh, as much,
uh, energy as they used to. Uh,
so we're all putting on weight,
water consumption, water consumption,
especially in arid parts of the world. Uh,
irrigation a necessary for agriculture.
This is a critical problem,
particularly related to climate
change, uh, which, uh, uh,
is causing experts to
predict that, that, uh, uh,
it's going to be increasingly
expensive to move water into dryer, uh,
environments.
Meaning that it's going to
be a core requirement to
ship those foods from longer
distances, uh, demanding higher energy.
Most of us don't really
have much knowledge of the
energy it takes to produce a,
say a, a, a bowl, a piece as
opposed to a bowl of oatmeal or a,
a a stake. And that's quite
curious. The amount of energy,
uh, that obviously increases with distance
from the source of production to the
source of consumption.
Uh,
but we really don't pay any attention to
that and we don't have any way of, of,
uh, uh, measuring it. This, by the way,
would be a terrific term paper if somebody
still thinking about a research topic
for the course. Just take one
food. Uh, just take apples,
figure out where apples are produced
in the world, uh, figure out, uh, uh,
where Yale buys it's apples and try to
come up with a metric for the energy
involved in moving an apple,
uh,
from point of production to the point
of consumption. So you know, you,
you could imagine a society,
uh, decades into the future, uh,
where you could take your iPhone and you
could walk up to a grocery store shelf
and you know,
you could hold the,
the Barcode on the food are on the side
of the shelf next to your phone and you
could call up information on
where the food came from. A,
you could call it information
on its energy. Uh,
was it produced using
artificial chemicals, uh, or uh,
what kinds of fertilizers were used to
produce it so that we could get a whole
new level of understanding
of, uh, energy and, uh,
the environmental health
of our different products,
including issues such as a protein
content and fat content type of fat,
a amount of salt, et cetera. Right now,
most of us walk through the marketplace,
uh, really blind to these issues, uh,
blinds to the environmental effects of,
of food production,
a blind to also to the energy consumption.
We also have very little understanding
of food processing and I want you to
think about a couple of commodities
that you experience on a routine basis.
You take cotton, for example,
that I just showed you,
a picture of a cotton is a cotton
seeds are put into a machine.
Uh, they are ground up. Uh, then
there are, are sprayed by a solvent.
The solvent extracts the oils and
the oil drips down into, into vats.
Uh, it gets mixed with other kinds of
vegetable oils and ends it's way, uh,
of winds its way into,
into supermarkets.
How about grapes while grapes have
water extracted from them? Uh,
and they are turned into raisins. Uh, uh,
you can think of a variety of different
foods. Corn as another example,
a oil is extracted from corn. How is
it done? It's done using a solvent.
But what happens to the solvent?
Where does it go?
Or there residues of the solvent in
corn oil. And the answer is often yes,
the residents do, uh, uh, persist.
They do get into, into the food supply.
Uh,
but we have very little understanding of
what happens to food when it leaves the
farm on its way to, uh,
to our dinner table.
Food packaging is a topic that
we'll take on a, in a few weeks. Uh,
particularly with respect to plastics and
the absence of our understanding, the,
the origin of the plastic or
the content of the plastic,
the energy that it takes to produce the
plastic is really quite striking. Uh,
all of the plastic waste that surrounds
most of the meats that are produced and
available in grocery
stores is thrown away.
And there's almost no hope that any
of that plastic is ever recycled.
It's simply discarded and it's burned.
Uh,
and many of the plastics contain chemicals
that you really don't want to breathe,
or if they're buried in landfills,
they will leach.
They will break down gradually and they
will leach into soils and underlying
water supplies. Uh, and as I mentioned
in an earlier lecture in every landfill,
uh, among the 300,000
that exists in the nation,
you can find these residues of plastic
in the soil and the underlying what
groundwater supply.
So the key environmental and
health problems associated
with our methods of food
production, uh, include pesticides. Uh,
and I'll talk a bit about pesticides
today and the structure of pesticide law.
Uh,
there are now some 25,000 pesticides,
uh, that are, are, uh,
packaged in different ways and
sold in different combinations.
In the United States alone
in the world marketplace,
there are 75,000 different pesticide
products that had been registered by
different nations.
How about fertilizers?
When some parts of the world human
waste is used as fertilizers,
animal waste is used,
but also there are a fossil fuel
based fertilizers that are, are,
are very common.
So increasingly we find fertilizer,
uh, being used as farmers, uh,
continually plant and replant the same
field. They don't let let it lie fallow.
They don't plant crops that can fix
nitrogen into the soil. Uh, so that,
uh, they have to, they have to add an
order to officially coloring agents.
Most of you probably do not pay too much
attention to coloring agents in your
food.
But there's a very interesting history
of coloring agents and different nations
have different laws and some,
some of these agents are natural,
others are artificial. Uh,
but, uh, uh, that, that would
be another great paper topic.
Just take a,
take a,
a look carefully at what we know about
different kinds of chemicals that are
used to color foods, flavors, a,
also artificial flavors and natural
flavors. Uh, what do you know about them?
They do not have to be labeled
under federal food law. Uh,
so natural flavors is a, uh,
a, an umbrella category. Uh,
artificial flavors also is, and uh, uh,
this is a huge industry. If you decided
you wanted to produce, say a, a,
a new concoction, maybe it
would be a coconut flavored, uh,
apple sauce will, you
could basically get a, uh,
some sort of pureed fruit, uh, of
different sorts. Maybe pair, maybe apple,
maybe peaches. You can ground it out and
grind the popup and uh, by processing it,
you'd likely lose all the flavor.
So you'd have to figure out how to
put the flavor back into it. Well,
you could do that really easily.
I encourage you to go online
and take a look at the, uh,
international flavors and
fragrances institute. Uh,
and it will give you a list of firms,
chemical companies all over the world.
That will will allow you to say,
yes, I want to make, make a, a,
a coconut lime apple sauce or a, uh, uh,
a root beer flavored chewing gum. Uh,
they will give you the, uh, the, uh,
chemical company's name,
and they will provide you with the,
the essence is necessary, uh, to create
the product. Also, you may not know,
but a fragrances are commonly used in
food because fragrances will trigger the
same, uh, nerve response, uh,
in your mouth and in your mind
that the flavors will trigger.
So to create a sense that you're eating,
say, root beer flavored oatmeal, uh,
they could simply use a, a, a drop of, of
a fragrance to give you that impression.
So packaging materials processing
affects a contamination of air, water,
and food on genetic modification. These
are all critical, highly debated topics,
uh, around the world, given the fact that
many nations have different standards.
Whereas the marketplace, the global
marketplace clearly is, is uh, uh,
moving commodities at a, at a lightening
pace, across national boundaries,
creating serious legal problems,
uh,
for firms that to have to
understand, uh, the, the difficulty,
the difficult, uh, uh, a problem of,
of having different regulations in
different countries and there are deeper,
deeper problems here associated
with the food supply.
And they include a really a fractured
legal and regulatory responsibility.
And I'll, I'll talk more about that
in a few moments. A private science,
the fact that the majority of science
that underlies a understanding the, the,
uh, environmental effects,
the health effects, uh,
the energy consumption required in
order to produce and move food, uh,
the,
the energy required to a,
to deal with the waste that the science
is being conducted in the private sector.
It's often not available
to the public sector.
So trade secrecy laws is quite
important in this case. Uh,
and that it often prevents you from
understanding in detail what you'd really
need to know in order to take
control over your own diet.
Worker safety is another deeper problem
that we don't pay much attention to.
If you look at, uh, the, uh, the farm,
the farm worker poisoning data
becomes apparent that, uh, uh,
workers are often, uh, not
well-protected. They're often, uh,
uh, uh, not monitored. They
often do not have, uh, uh,
insurance and, uh, uh,
health care, uh, so that, uh,
it's a neglected population.
Migrant workers traditionally
have been exploited in a,
almost every nation in the world.
But even in our,
our country where we think we
have highly sophisticated law, uh,
workers really are not protected
nearly the same as you or I would be,
so that there are different
standards for allowable risk, uh,
for workers than there are
four. For a Uri say, uh,
from purchasing food in,
in the marketplace. Uh,
different contamination limits.
Uh, another deeper problem is the
narrative advantage of the producers.
If you look at the scale of the
advertising industry and their,
their methods of
advertising and this wall.
So it would be a great topic
for a paper on what are their,
what are their tonic
dominant test strategies? Uh,
how do they make claims
of a product benefit, uh,
either that it is natural,
that it is helpful,
how far can they go and what laws
restrict what they can claim.
What about their requirements to,
uh,
disclose risks that are known to be
associated with, with their foods.
So it's, it's interesting that the
organic food industry evolved basically,
uh, growing from a strategy
that, that, uh, uh,
proclaims that a certain
class of chemicals is not
present in the food supply.
So synthetic organic pesticides
are not allowed to be used, uh,
in organic foods.
Now that doesn't mean that those that
are producing nonorganic foods have to
label what synthetic organic
chemicals are in their food.
So you can think about different legal
strategies that might be employed in
order to provide the consumer
with knowledge that would
be really necessary to
understand what they're reading.
Uh,
public subsidies also a are a worthy
topic for somebody interested in trying to
transform the, the, uh, international
food system. So, uh, if you, uh,
look at the subsidies carefully,
and you can do this now because there
was a group in Washington called the
environmental working group that
put together a terrific website. Uh,
so you can go to the website and you can
find your home state and your county or
your town and you can figure out which
farmers are getting which subsidies. Uh,
and what you'll see is that that,
uh,
industrialized a commodities such
as corn and wheat and cotton, uh,
they're receiving the bulk of the
subsidies in the nation as opposed to the
organic farmers or farmers
that are beyond organic, uh,
who basically receive no
subsidy. So that, uh, you know,
government funds could be used to, to
innovate, to, to really transform, uh,
the structure of, of agriculture
in the nation. Uh, but, uh, uh,
this is not likely in the
near future a land values, uh,
how to land values play into the
pattern of farming and agriculture that,
that we currently see. Well, you know,
what I suggested earlier in the
talk was that, uh, you know,
as urban areas and suburban areas,
a sprawl out into undeveloped lands are
they commonly will cause property values
in lands that are nearby to
increase the commercial value there.
They're a residential value
or their industrial value, uh,
may shoot up quite quickly as
a, as a city expands. So that a,
the value of the, of the
land, uh, from the, uh,
and in terms of its productivity for
different crops often can't compete with
this rising, uh, uh, property value.
Uh, so that, that the farmer sells out.
Also the agricultural land, uh,
it's flat generally. Uh, it,
it also is, is, uh, uh, not forested.
And what this means is that a,
it's really easy to develop.
So you can imagine the, uh, the problem
of, of developing in a forested area.
Uh, it's much more expensive
for land development.
So you find the rate of
transformation of farmland, uh, from,
from, uh, uh, especially in
the rural parts of the u s,
uh, that, uh, are in the target
zone for urban expansion. Uh,
these lands are being shifted into,
into residential and commercial
use at a very rapid rate. So, uh,
the fundamental problem that
I think we face right now is,
is one of intelligence.
And I don't mean to imply that a,
it's an absence of capacity to
understand these things. It's,
it's an absence of producing the knowledge
and making it publicly accessible to
consumers in a way that a
really could empower you to,
to react in the marketplace in a
way that would send messages back to
corporations.
Uh,
messages that I think really are
often much more powerful and, uh,
often more listened to than
messages sent by regulators.
So I'd like you to think about
corn and ethanol for just a moment.
And, uh, the, the increasing subsidy
for the production of ethanol, uh,
that, uh, you know, will
oxygenate fuels and a is,
is a required by a different
levels of government,
including the environmental
protection agency
as a way of improving
air quality. Uh, but, uh,
what is increasingly
apparent is that, uh, uh,
the ethanol in subsidy has caused, uh, uh,
corn prices to rise quite dramatically.
Uh,
because more of the farmers are putting
these ethanol production plants on their
property and they're not shutting
the corn into the food supply.
Now, there also was an, uh,
an over abundance of enthusiasm among
the farmers to produce the ethanol.
So the ethanol market, uh,
started to collapse. Uh,
and, uh, this is, uh, this is hurt the
farmers throughout the United States.
Think now about the one area, uh, and,
uh, the area of chemical application,
uh, particularly pesticides. Uh, this is
an interesting area in that, uh, it, it,
it demands that you think about
a real variety of laws. Uh,
the Federal Food Drug and
cosmetic act on the top here,
the federal insecticide fungicide and
rodenticide act and the Food Quality
Protection Act.
These are the dominant statutes in the
United States that apply to a pesticide,
uh, control, uh, but
other laws as well, uh,
are necessary to understand and have some,
some control over,
uh, pesticides including the safe
drinking water act. And other words,
one would need to worry about the
application of billions of pounds of
pesticides in the United
States every year. Uh,
because the pesticides the often
don't just go away. Uh, they,
they often will move down through soils
and into groundwater supplies. Uh, so,
uh, we'll talk a bit later in
the, in the week about, uh, the,
the problem with managing, uh,
drinking water quality by the way, uh,
the government, uh, uh, in
its food intake surveys, uh,
concludes that the number one food that
everybody eats in the United States is
water. Water is classified as a food
under the food, drug and cosmetic act. Uh,
so that,
uh,
worrying about a water contamination
is a really important issue and
understanding the way that a chemical
release into the atmosphere as well as
into a, on to plants in,
into the landscape, uh,
that that could contaminate drinking
water even if it goes through a filtration
plant, uh, that, uh, often is
the case for many urban areas.
Resource Conservation and Recovery Act,
uh,
that we talked a bit about
last week and Super Fund. Uh,
most of these sites have pesticides
within them and they are classified as
hazardous sites in part because
of the pesticides that are there.
But pesticides were in the, uh, recites
in the circle of sites on VA case.
Uh, predominantly, uh, chemicals
that are persistent were,
were applied back in the
30s, forties, and 50s.
The toxic substance control
act does deal with pesticides.
The Hazardous Material
Transportation Act does as well.
National Environmental Policy Act that a,
we talked about last week,
endangered species act if you have a,
an endangered species, uh, that, uh,
and it's habitat has been defined. It's
a normally illegal to apply pesticides,
uh, in that, in that Habitat, uh,
the Wilderness Act would prevent
pesticides from being applied within its
boundaries. Uh, and the
manufacturer of pesticides often
produces a airborne resumes that are
regulated under the Clean Air Act.
Uh, and also the release via
pipes from those plants, uh, uh,
is regulated under the clean
water act. Uh, but as well, uh,
you can imagine the problem of spraying
chemicals year after year and a
landscape, uh, and then, uh, you have,
uh, rainstorms coming in the spring.
Give you a good example of that.
Atrazine, which is an herbicide,
it's a pre emergent herbicides.
So they plant the corn,
but before the corn sprouts,
they'll spray the landscape,
the atrazine often in the spring.
Uh, so always in the spring,
actually in particularly in the Midwest,
uh, after the spring rains come,
you can measure as it spikes in atrazine,
in the Mississippi River and most of the
mid Western rivers and these rivers in
the Midwest provide water supplies
for tens of millions of people. Uh,
and the filtration of the
plants will not take it out.
So both the clean water act and the safe
drinking water act come into play in
that case.
And the Occupational Safety and Health
Act also is designed to protect a worker
safety. Uh, but as I said earlier,
it often sets standards that are
far above standards that are,
are set for a non worker environments.
So it's a very complicated body of law.
But for this reason,
pesticides becomes a good, a good
window to, to understand law. Uh,
one way to think about this is that
it's driven by two, two things really.
One is that pesticides are intentionally
toxic substances. They're not,
they're not like, say,
just some new chemical that
somebody designs a, you know,
for, uh, to, to be added to a, to
plastic to make it stronger. Uh,
that wasn't designed, uh, to,
uh, to kill a different species.
It was designed to provide
some functionality,
but pesticides is a group of chemicals,
uh,
were specifically designed
to injure either a plant, uh,
an insect, a, some other species. In fact,
some of the nerve gases that were designed
to during World War II and, and, uh, uh,
in the 1920s by Great Britain and Germany,
Nazi Germany,
they were designed
specifically to harm humans.
And many of these nerve gases
have been diluted down, uh,
for agricultural purposes. Uh, so that,
uh, all species have been targets, uh,
for the development of this class
of biocides. It's number one,
they're intentionally toxic substances.
And number two, to get their effect,
they've got to be released to the
environment in, in great quantities.
So you release a chemical
or the environment, uh,
the atomic weapons testing history
tells us you better understand something
about where it goes.
And pesticide history is replete with
examples where people paid too little
attention.
Now I want to,
I want to step back and take you into the
earlier part of the century and I want
you to think about a, a, a
very serious problem, uh,
at that point in time and a problem
that persistent and that's malaria.
Malaria is a, an illness that's
transmitted by a parasite. Uh,
it's, uh, the Anopheles
mosquito and a, all of its,
all of its variance,
uh,
had the capacity to take the parasite up
from the blood of an infected animal or
an uninfected human.
So if a,
if you had malaria and an inset
came and landed on you, uh,
the monopolies mosquito would first
spit a little bit of an anticoagulant
through its proboscis into
your, into your body to, uh, uh,
help you bleed a little bit, uh, and
then it will suck your blood, uh,
into its stomach cavity.
Uh, and with that blood,
it would pull in malaria parasites
that are in your body than perhaps a,
I didn't have assume
I didn't have malaria.
That mosquito flew over and landed
on me. Uh, it would bite me and, uh,
when it would insert it's anticoagulant,
uh,
in its saliva in me, they would
transmit parasites into my body.
And that's the way that this illness
is transmitted from person to person.
The parasite, uh, uh,
has the capacity to live for nine to 11
days inside the body of a mosquito and
the sea, kind of an interesting
issue that, that, uh,
the encephalitis virus last
from 10 to 25 days. And, uh,
thank God the Aids virus, uh, lasts
only one to two days, so that the,
the longevity of,
of different viruses or bacteria or
parasites inside different in insects,
uh, affects the rate of
transmission. So I want you to,
to also understand the scale
of this problem in the world.
And today there are about between
300 and 500 million people, uh,
that are clinically disabled by malaria,
meaning that they want,
they're walking around with this parasite
in their bodies that is sapping them
of energy, that is giving
them periodic fevers, uh,
that makes them more susceptible
to other kinds of illnesses. Uh,
and 40% of the world's population
live in areas that, that are at risk,
meaning that the mosquitoes in that
area are capable of transmitting the
parasite. And you've got a large
population percentage that, uh, uh,
uh, also is carrying the
parasite and their bodies. The,
the core of the problem for malaria
in the world is, is really, uh,
in tropical regions and, and, uh,
particularly in Africa where 90% of
the incidents and mortality a exist.
And, uh, the,
the estimate right now by the World
Health Organization is that roughly one to
one and a half million people
die every year from malaria.
And the estimate over the 20th century
is about a hundred million people have
died from this illness.
It's quite striking that many people
have not understood the scale of this
problem.
So it's also clear if you read much
military history that a malaria was a very
serious problem in all wars.
So that if you go back to at
the time of, uh, uh, Napoleon,
or if you look at the, the, uh, uh,
history of world war one or World War II,
as,
as us or other countries moved
into tropical parts of the world,
a more casualties commonly
occurred, more lost days, uh, among,
among a gis occurred due to malaria
than it did to the direct effects of
casualties. There are also susceptible
populations, kids in endemic areas. Uh,
uh, although in epidemics all
age groups are affected, uh,
refugees and migrant populations and
those living in tents such those that are,
are, uh, fighting and
in the armed conflict,
it's all related to heightened
exposure being, being out in,
in an environment where, uh, you're,
you're exposing yourself to
being bitten by infected insects.
So you could also imagine that those,
that,
that work in mines or those that work
in forestry and tropical parts of the
world or, or agricultural workers,
they are also more at risk.
People that spend a timeout to outdoors
in the tropics in endemic areas are more
at risk,
as are those with reduced immunity who
has reduced immunity while pregnant women.
Pregnant women are extremely susceptible
to a very serious illness from,
from pregnancy and also
miscarriages. Uh, also the,
the very young young children,
those that are already had their immune
system compromised or in parts of, of,
uh, uh, the poorest
parts of the world. Uh,
you often have the background
high incidents of acute
respiratory infections or
diarrheal diseases that reduces a
strength and immunity and makes one more
susceptible to to this illness.
Well,
one of the ways of controlling
malaria included pesticides. Uh,
and here's an example of a worker in 1939
and an outbreak in natal Brazil when a
mosquito actually hitchhiked from Africa
on a mail boat and an athlete Gambi a
mosquito, uh, not, not, uh,
uh, indigenous to, to Brazil.
And so they finally figured out that it
hitchhiked on this mail freighter, uh,
was able to, to, uh, uh, are,
are a number of them did.
And they were able to establish a, uh, uh,
a fairly large and robust population that
it occurred during a rainy season when
they had exactly the right pool of
water standing on, on the areas. Uh,
some mosquitoes actually are interesting
and that they prefer a streams or
rivers that are,
are moving really quickly is habitat.
Others like very Stillwater, others
like shallow water, uh, so that, uh,
there are hundreds and hundreds of
different species of mosquitoes capable of
transmitting, uh, these, these illnesses
such as malaria or dengue fever,
yellow fever. So that understanding
the ecology here is really important.
Uh,
one way of dealing with the problem
and not understanding the ecology is
basically to simply spray broad
areas and landscape with pesticides,
which is what they did in this case.
Uh,
when US troops invaded a
islands in the Pacific, in the,
in the war against Japan,
uh, in the mid 1940s,
the incidents among a US gis was often
3000 per thousand per year as it was
reported, meaning that everybody
on the island had on average, uh,
malaria at least three times so that the
casualty rates here caused them to have
to move troops in and out of the island
much more rapidly than they normally
would have.
The development of the chlorine industry,
uh,
is a very important part of this story
because chlorine is a key component of
many pesticides that were developed
in the 1940s, uh, including DDT.
A chlorinated hydrocarbons,
uh, include, uh,
Alderman Dieldrin have to Clore
chlordane, uh, chemicals. Uh,
curiously the became the target of the
environmental protection agency as soon
as it was formed in the
1970s. And why is that? Well,
because all of the properties that
made strontium 90 a dangerous compound,
it persisted.
It moved widely through the environment.
It will contaminate virtually
every compartment, uh,
and it would build up in food chains,
marine food chains, as well as, as a, uh,
an ecosystems, uh, in
terrestrial ecosystems.
It would get in people's bodies and it
will be transmitted via breastmilk across
generations. So the search was on, uh,
during this explosion in the
chemical industry in the 1940s, uh,
for a variety of new chemicals that
would replace the older metals like Paris
Green. Uh, in the previous shot here,
this gentleman is mixing Paris Green,
which is arsenic.
He's mixing it by hand and he's just
basically just throwing it out across a
stream so that the,
the heavy metals used earlier in the
century were replaced by the chlorinated
hydrocarbons.
And gradually they figured out that
a DDT in particular was exceptionally
effective at controlling the Paris, the
insects that would transmit the parasite,
uh, that, uh, uh, is malaria
that causes malaria. Uh,
so this was first tried a, as refugees
moved through Europe during World War II.
And here's an example of taking basically
a variant on a bicycle pump and taking
a hose. And, and uh, the
drill that was followed was a,
there was one shot down the
back of the neck. There was
one shot, uh, down, uh, the,
the, the waistband and then up into the
lower part of the shirt, front and back,
and then up both of the pant legs.
So that tens of thousands of
people were lined up in Rome,
walking through these stations as people
that were, were sanitation workers, then,
uh, would basically man these pumps in
spray people. This, this attempt, uh,
brought the typhus epidemic,
uh, that is transmitted by,
by fleas to a close,
uh,
extremely rapidly within a matter of a
couple of weeks when it was anticipated
to, to go on for, for
months, if not years.
Another example of a child
at the time being sprayed.
So gradually, uh, they recognize the DDT
would kill so many different species, uh,
that it was sprayed across marsh lands
and landscapes and they realized a,
at the end of World War II that they
should also release it for agricultural
purposes.
So by 1950,
a DDT was being marketed as a,
uh,
an effective way to control pests that
would threatened just about every crop.
You could imagine more than
300 different crops. Uh,
critical components of us agriculture,
uh, were recommended to be,
to be treated by, by this single
chemical. So Ddt is good for me. Uh,
there's a little jingle that went
along with this that kids would sing.
There was no understanding of, of
its bioaccumulation capacity. Uh,
even though they understood that they
only had to spray it once in an area, uh,
and whereas other compounds,
they would have to kind of come
back and keep on spraying. So, uh,
I'll tell that story in
just a moment. But, uh, uh,
here's another example of Jones beach in
New York, uh, where the, the county, uh,
public health department is driving
down the beach. Uh, and, uh,
uh, the sign that is on the side of the
struck this truck, you can't read it,
I'm sure, but it's telling it,
it says DDT powerful insecticide,
harmless to humans. Very little
understanding of what they were doing.
A kids were running down, people eating
their hamburgers. A trucks would come by,
kids would be sitting at picnic
tables, the picnic table,
all the food, and, and, uh,
the kids included would be sprayed very
little understanding of kind of the
basic ecology of this compound.
So it persists in the soil.
It was later discovered 10 to 35 years and
in the atmosphere, uh, for three years.
And that, just as an aside, uh,
they decided that they were going
to just test the air just by chance.
Somebody said, well, you know, this is
a ridiculous thing to do. Uh, but, uh,
30 meters off the ocean on a freighter,
a halfway between San Francisco and Tokyo,
uh,
they took air measurements and found
that a DDT was present in the air in the
middle of the Pacific Ocean, and that
there was a latitudinal gradient gradient.
So that as you approach the equator,
you would have a higher concentration
of Ddt, uh, then if you moved away.
And why was that?
Well,
it's because of the increased number of
pests that you get closer to the equator
and tropical parts of the world. Uh, led
those nations to springboard EDT, uh,
both for sanitation, public
health purposes, but also
for crop protection purposes
was also found in human tissues.
Uh,
and it probably is still detectable
in your tissue. And in fact,
I was looking at the food and Drug
Administration's a records on pesticide
residues in the food supply. It's kind
of striking and that, uh, uh, even today,
DDT is, is one of the most detected
chemicals in the u s food supply,
particularly in milk products,
uh, at very, very low levels.
But it's a good indicator of the longterm
persistence of this compound and why
we need to pay attention to
that. Also, uh, like strontium,
it was detected in breast
milk, uh, meaning that, uh,
if, if you were breastfed, uh,
your mom probably had a higher
concentration, uh, then, uh, uh,
you do. But, uh, any body
burden that you've got is
coming from, uh, probably, uh,
just a stores from your, your mom
because it's compound binds to body fat.
It's Lipophilic as opposed
to hydrophylic. Uh, and,
and, uh, uh, that's the, uh, that's
the way that a, you'd be exposed.
Your grandmother probably hadn't residues
far higher than, uh, than your mother.
But this kind of transgenerational
effect is, is quite curious.
In 1971, uh, the effort
to regulate it was,
was really pioneered
by Vermont of Vermont,
passed a law banning
DDT use and the state.
And they had formerly been spraying it
on their force to control for Gypsy Moss,
uh,
that,
that was followed in Wisconsin in 1970
by a black man in New York in 1971 by a
band. And finally, I'm actually
the British also, uh, decided that,
uh, uh, this was not a
problem that uh, uh, the,
the support for agriculture and the
control of public health was so important
that it should be continued to be used.
Whereas the Soviet found that, uh,
it was worthy of a band that came
out strongly in favor of a band.
Finally,
in 1972,
I remember EPA was created in 1969.
Uh,
it actually physically came into
being in 1970 [inaudible] 1972,
uh,
William Ruckelshaus,
who was the former administrator of
the environmental protection agency,
decided that they should move ahead
because of the effects on wildlife, uh,
but also the, the, uh,
cancer threat to humans, uh,
he felt was sinking it significant
enough to justify its regulation.
And I know you can't
read this, but, uh, uh,
there's an interesting phrase and this is
on the, uh, uh, in the New York Times, uh,
that, uh, effective
December 31st, 1972, uh,
in the meantime, he explained growers
and cotton, peanuts, soybeans, uh,
the three crops that account for almost
the total domestic use of DDT, uh,
will get instructions in the handling
of a substitute pesticide methyl
parathyroid on the substitute
is, uh, can't really read, Oh,
is nontoxic. Uh, but unlike DDT, uh,
it degrades quickly, so they're
trading off a persistent chemical,
uh, uh, for one that
degrades quite quickly,
not really understanding what the
longterm effect might be. Curiously, uh,
the company that manufactured the
companies that manufactured DDT, uh,
said to themselves, well, you know,
is there a way that we could modify the
chemical structure of the compound a and
s sell something that would
be a minor variant? Uh,
and they produced a compound
known as known as Dika fall. Uh,
that was the only a little bit
different. And, uh, low and behold,
uh, in all the parts of the country,
uh, where Dika fall was sprayed,
they found similar effects in wildlife,
particularly among a large raptors. Uh,
so in the, in the south west were an
in the south that were cotton is grown.
They found it being, they found Daggerfall
building up just the way DDT had a,
so it was Lipophilic, it was
bioaccumulative and, and, uh,
uh, basically, uh, became
equally worrisome to the
environmental protection agency.
So they banned DDT and 82
and [inaudible] 72, uh,
they got around to recognizing that,
uh, uh, not only was Dika fall,
uh,
having the same effects,
but it also is contaminated by
DDT at a level of about 15%. Uh,
and that they needed to get that chemical
out of the food plies in and out of
the, uh, uh, environment as well.
So it took until 1986 for
them to actually, uh, uh,
move ahead with a regulation and then
to work its way out of production took
until the early 1990s.
So this is the band that wasn't a band,
the band that took effect in [inaudible]
72 that really was not effective until
the early 1990s. Now,
if you then jump ahead,
fast forward to 1999,
uh,
you'll see that EPA is getting around
to studying methyl [inaudible] on the
recommended substitute by
William Ruckelshaus. In 1972,
uh, he decided, oh, well,
in 1999,
uh,
EPA decided this chemical is more
dangerous than we thought. In fact,
[inaudible] is responsible for more farm
worker deaths and poisoning than any
other chemical in history.
Uh,
not only is it a far more
acutely toxic than DDT, but,
uh, it, uh, also persisted
longer than they believed.
So one of the, uh, uh, concerns
that we have today is, you know,
what are we going to do with respect
to the persistence of malaria, uh,
but also it's likely migration
into parts of the world, uh,
where it had been well controlled. And
if you look at, uh, where malaria, uh,
exists now, you'll see that, that, uh, uh,
malaria is a problem predominantly
in the tropical parts of the world,
also the poorest parts of the
world. Uh, and you'll see that, uh,
it's the expected range of malaria,
of,
of the different species of mosquitoes
that carry it. Uh, it's widening. It's,
it's widening right now in response to,
to a changing climatic conditions so that
the habitat is becoming more favorable
for disease transmission. Now,
the World Health Organization, uh,
recognize this and they called
together a group of people that, uh,
were expert in pesticides. And I
worked on pesticides for maybe, uh, uh,
15 years and worked with a group
of about seven other people, uh,
some from African nations to try to
understand how to manage malaria,
particularly in Africa,
who had gone along with the bands of EPA.
And most other high income nations in
the world, uh, and had phased it out.
It did not recommend the use of DDT
in any part of the world as of the mid
1970s,
but they want it to reconsider
this because it was so
inexpensive and it was so,
it was so effective. Uh, in part
because it was so persistent,
they realized that if it was
sprayed both indoors and outdoors,
it would cause the insects to
evolve resistance strains, uh,
that would be harder and harder
for them to manage. Uh, in fact,
many mosquitoes have developed
a resistance to, to, uh,
a DVT so that they sprayed it
on a wall inside a house. Uh,
the Anopheles mosquito would land
on the wall, but it could sense it,
it through its feet, uh, and it
would take off and that's it.
So it's a new behavioral response that
prevented it from absorbing a lethal dose.
So gradually the World
Health Organization, uh,
became concerned about increasing
incidents of malaria, uh,
particularly in Africa,
uh,
and convene this group to try to figure
out whether or not it made sense, uh, to,
to get behind a DDT
and, and to, to, uh, uh,
use it again and the next most effective
pesticide cost four times the level of
DDT. Uh, so this was a
problem and, uh, the,
the aid agencies were not willing to pay
this increased expense, so that, that, uh,
uh, who, uh, finally in 2006, uh,
gave DDT a clean bill of health, so to
speak, even though this group of experts,
uh, that, uh, uh,
convened in, in 2004, uh,
this group found that, well, you know,
using DDT is really not a good idea.
You should use a less toxic chemical
and one that has less persistent, uh,
that would be equally effective.
Uh, even though it costs more.
So it's a matter of finding the money
in order to pay for the chemical that
would protect human
health, uh, and, uh, uh,
environmental quality at the same time.
It would deal with the malaria problem.
So,
uh,
I'm at time and I'm going to stop there
and we'll come back on Thursday and take
a closer look at the variety of laws that
applied to food safety in the nation.
Thank you.